some new people moved into the
neighborhood they came from Wuhan the
epicenter of the deadly coronavirus
pandemic perhaps you be worried or angry
but it'd be hard to match the anger
brewing in Ukraine to just that
situation
[Applause]
[Music]
the past several days Ukraine has seen
violent clashes across the country
scores of policemen have been injured by
locals throwing bricks riot police have
been called in to disperse angry mobs
and it's all because the Ukrainian
authorities tried to do a good deed for
the international community they
accepted with open arms a number of
their countrymen and foreigners trying
to flee Wuhan by plane assuring the
public the passengers were 100%
coronavirus clean an important detail
when Ukraine itself has yet to see a
case of the disease a quarantine zone
was even set up at a health center in
Poltava just to be sure but the
protesters did all they could to stop
that plane from landing and when that
failed they started blocking roads until
riot police removed them by force
[Applause]
[Music]
the buses made it to their destination
in the end but their unwelcome reception
wasn't exactly what Kiev expected
president zalenski even called out the
protesters for showing the uglier side
of their humanity it's a shame that not
all of us can be proud of their humane
reaction the efforts to shut off
highways to block hospitals not to let
Ukrainians back to Ukraine
we're not demonstrating the best of our
character here especially given that the
majority of the passengers are under 30
- most of us they are almost children
children are not Ukraine's protesters
don't seem to be up for a game of
Russian roulette with the coronavirus
you